maintenant si vous allez par exemple
dans les Landes alors quelles sont les
cultures qui sont pratiquées dans les
Landes en cours d'agronomie il est
question de phage des sol et de culture
Bernard beofice est enseignant et
agriculteur ils ne sont pas de baisse de
morale dans les rangs beaucoup envie de
s'installer à peu près je sais pas 40 %
dans la classe et j'ai pas ressenti de
malêre contraire ils sont ils sont un
petit peu élément moteur ils sont
curieux ces élèves de BTS sont tous
autour de 20 ans ils sont passionnés
mais leur choix d'avenir peuvent varier
selon qu'ils sont enfant d'agriculteur
ou pas comme Florent si j'ai une
opportunité pourquoi pas me me destiné à
cette à agriculteur mais je me verrai
plus pour l'instant dans le par agricole
donc dans tout ce qui est conseil
justementes agriculteurs dans le
développement durable c'est plus
l'argent et les problèmes qu'on
rencontre en tant que bah non fille
fille d'agriculteur ou fils
d'agricultrice d'un point de vue bah les
terres acheter une exploitation faire un
prêt enfin c'est c'est compliqué
beaucoup moin chez les enfants
d'exploitants pas de doute ils
reprendront la ferme les inquiétudes
sont ailleurs B malheureusement j'ai
peur qu'on qu'on aille vers ça deux
types d'agriculture qu'on perde en
diversité et qu'on se retrouve donc oui
donc avec un côté effectivement petites
exploitations écolobo et et des très
grosses exploitations que ce soit en
élevage ou en céréales avec des surfaces
importantes faut pas se lancer comme ça
faut réfléchir bien prendre le temps de
de poser les bases après bah pour une
installation à court terme pourquoi pas
faut faut voir ce qui peut être
envisageable de faire et surtout si le
projet est viable et si on peut en vivre
aussi lucide motivés et pragmatique ces
agriculteurs en devenir savent que
l'agriculture de demain ne sera pas
celle d'hier mais il se disent prêt à
relever le
défi